life has been a day-to-day struggle for
Emanuel Leno since he contracted Ebola
his parents and little sister lost their
lives to the fatal disease after it
broke out in West Africa last year a
total of eleven thousand people died
across the region but Emanuel was killed
he lost his job however due to the fear
and stigma while his neighbors and
relatives now avoid him Kenny Manuel
re-establish a normal life for himself
against the odds
Emmanuel leno's shares this residential
yard in the Guinean capital conakry with
his five siblings and around 100
neighbors
everything here reminds him of his
mother she was the first to be taken ill
with the virus Kingdom a little Kim I'm
a monk imprisoned the symptoms she had
matched exactly what we heard on the
radio Don Coppola me so I had to take
her to dunk a hospital personally I
appreciate nobody here wanted to touch
her via lumbar kid I carried her into a
taxi took you to a hospital I in part
pecan apple she died a little later in
the Ebola first-aid station yeah Harvey
Nevada triage led boyz ii men on
celibacy Ledisi d ella tambien la
Bollywood et al back home emmanuel
warned his neighbors about the virus but
nobody took him seriously it was only
when a series of people fell ill that
the villagers allowed Red Cross workers
to come in Emmanuel supported them where
he could being one of the few people
here who can read and write on
fellowship want a comprar la be carried
out checks and took children's
temperatures every day if it was over 39
degrees I will take the child to
hospital myself in a taxi because no
ambulances were available you're paler
taxi met Don Pardo they would then
disinfect the taxi while I waited in the
isolation ward with the child I brought
18 people to hospital in total and
eventually I was contaminated myself
Jaquan Daniela Darren me a position he
spent 21 days fighting against death
when Emanuele came home cured everything
had changed he was now head of his
family with himself in his sister left
to fend for their younger siblings he
had to drop out of school and lost his
job at a local bar
meda pillow casa feminine mom I can't
find the job since I was sick to lap
when my boss told everyone in the
neighborhood I had a bola donkeys
obvious with them wherever I apply for
jobs now at hotels and pubs the first
thing everyone says is you have Ebola
well a tecate Roma non pour toujours pas
Roman alma de que se toma by Ebola tick
his neighbors have likewise been keeping
their distance as if there were an
invisible wall between them with
Emmanuel's relatives having disowned him
to life has become hugely intimidating
even shopping is problematic the kiosk
owner across the road treats him with
suspicion he doesn't want me here
the kiosk owner is afraid and cautious
of coming into physical contact with
Emmanuel every morning he sets off for
the biggest market in conakry there he
can at least earn a little money
shifting goods from A to B one of his
potential customers recognizes him and
chases him away everyone feminine but
he's got a bowler and I don't want to
get infected he's a garnish a solution
one in manual tries his luck elsewhere
he appeals to the warehouse workers that
he's no longer infected and would only
touch the boxes
eventually they relent
there's only three boxes worth of work a
little over one euro for each trip so is
it heavy it's very heavy truck battery
it takes him half an hour but he's not
yet earned enough for the day Emmanuel
next tries his luck at the Red Cross the
manager at the warehouse tasks him with
bringing contaminated Ebola protective
suits to the incinerator having survived
Ebola Emmanuel is now immune an
advantage in this line of work
yeah the differ hard and be very much
Sasha be transported I can transport at
least ten loads like this a day for
example and they pay by the trip you've
got any ladders are satisfied I wait
until the evening to count up what I've
earned I can get 50 to 100,000 kidney in
France which equals the daily wage of
five to ten euros and took our work but
it does give me plenty of muscles even
if that wasn't my objective seizures at
the bar
after work it's time to go home
Ali badara carlo from the Red Cross is
paying a visit today he gives everyone
the Ebola greeting touching fists rather
than a potentially risky handshake so
nobody's been to see you all one since
you were last year nobody can you tell
me how you all are doing absolutely and
while our dokie we're all traumatized we
get stigmatized everywhere and even here
we don't really feel at home mum down we
all have to sleep in the same room
nobody lose your money Muslim pushes the
London sham Ali is unable to help out in
that regard the Red Cross is in charge
of hygiene and wants to chlorinate the
well Emmanuel asks him not to fearing
that the neighbors will assume Ebola is
back if they see the red cross at work
on our own la ta affected a la maladie
yes we were sick we were in hospital
it's you know dear encoder we survived
but how will people coming here with
soap chlorine help us we are elavil mms
abbas akhiyon wale will it bring back
our parents I mean indo para nambi Willa
chlorine help us to go back to school or
give us something to eat he one and only
our minds you rumors and patent untruths
about Ebola persist in Guinea Ali is
organizing a radio show to set the
record straight for the population he's
invited in many well to tell his story
on air this evening as they make their
way to the radio station Ali tries again
to convince him annual of the benefits
of chlorinating the well
the pretty much kiss it for them Ebola
is spread by dirty hands just like
cholera and other diseases they're all
related to insufficient sanitary
standards all I can do is repeat what I
say to everyone lost your hands and
listen to what the helpers are saying
the Red Cross has a cooperative
agreement with the private broadcaster
to produce a one hour weekly show about
Ebola
the broadcaster takes his own
precautions requiring everyone to wash
their hands and have their temperature
taken everyone here has a nice income
and an education a different world for
Emanuel the radio show is broadcasted
the local language susu to ensure the
message hits home the hon romagna d yeah
well I get a boner claimed two and a
half thousand victims in Guinea the Red
Cross organized the show to publicize
the fate of survivors and take a stance
against stigmatization Emanuel is the
main guest and sees an opportunity in
his participation he can't stop talking
telling his whole story in heart-rending
detail it's easier for him to talk about
it and Su Su than in French many before
him a queer nakhaba Guido bar oh we're
free ma after my mother died my father's
condition worsened wallah you're not
often they told me to bring him to the
Ebola treatment center in a Hummer then
he died and ever since I've been
responsible for a family of five
children what is the host concludes by
asking listeners to support Ebola
survivors like him annual
w/o you yeah buying now everyone in
guinea knows what my situation is like
after the show the presenter suggests he
look online for work or scholarships she
gives him a few website addresses to
give him an alternative to low-paying
menial work
Emmanuel knows a good cyber cafe in
downtown conakry he's going to follow up
and those tips from the radio host even
if his computer skills aren't too
advanced
the trivial question is it inshallah I
found something in the job vacancies at
UNICEF but it's not here in the capital
conakry it's in the center in the middle
of the country which is around 400
kilometers from here Larry show you how
pretty silly research it that's too far
away I have to take care of my family
thank you I copy that Emmanuel takes
down the address of the online
recruitment market to continue job
hunting another time back home he meets
bara kaluga the owner of the entire
complex since Emanuel's relatives have
turned their backs on him his landlord
has become a father figure for the young
man anwar essay on sample to woman we've
become one big family John he's kind to
us and have a lots of thank him for just
got paliza it must never said about word
to me even when I've been unable to pay
my rent and my buddy Larry but when I
asked him if he can wait he says no
problem rajula your buddy's a pocket
he's never stopped me in my made any
kind of problems for me in Miami John
Ellis you see in my co-maid O'Neill
astray Emmanuel wishes there were more
people like his landlord all over the
city he fears it could take several
years yet however until former Ebola
patients are no longer treated as social
outcasts no no no se palapa say para la
ba Baba Sehgal men